Let's go next to our caller from the seven
Oh six area code.
Who is calling today from seven zero six.
Oh, Hey David.
This is Kyle from Orlando, Florida.
Hey Kyle.
What's up?
Hey.
Um, so, uh, I work for Disney and, um, as
part of our union contract, we were able to
get a $15 an hour, uh, by 2021.
Right.
Um, which I think is great, but, um, you know,
in 2016 we were having the debate about $15
being the minimum wage.
Uh, but you know, given that inflation is
a thing, uh, shouldn't we be talking about
$20 an hour now?
And tying that to inflation.
Yeah.
So this is something that I've mentioned many
times when the $15 an hour minimum wage thing
started, and it was often not for right now,
but let's get up to $15 by some future date.
A lot of the [inaudible]
outreach, a lot of the outrage was just bad
faith outrage.
Some of the outrage seemed not to take into
account that merely because of inflation,
it would have really only been like $12 at
the time that the conversation started, or
$13 at the time that, you know, the conversation's
been going on at a lot of different be tied
to, to inflation automatically because otherwise
this conversation will literally never end.
Right, right.
The, I mean, do you think like shooting for
$20 an hour anyways, and then, I mean, maybe
we can say, Oh, well the compromise will be,
you know, $15 an hour.
Um, just as a way to, I guess to get ahead
of the Republicans.
I don't know that I would just
throw out a random number, but there are good
studies that say, listen, if we had indexed
to inflation going back to 1968, it should
now be, you know, like 1770 an hour.
That's where it should be.
Let's negotiate from there.
And, and here's something that now a lot of
people on the right won't, won't like that,
but let me say something that a lot of people
on the left won't like, which I think does
make sense.
I've said before
four, I think that the minimum wage needs
to be regionalized to some degree because
if you have a low cost of living state where
you're talking about going from seven 50 to
15, that is very different than a high cost
of living state where you're talking about
going from 12 to 15.
So I do think that there is something too
we should look at.
I don't know if it's on a state by state level,
Metro areas or whatever the case may be, but
there should be consideration given to both
cost of living, uh, as well as, um, uh, what
the, the current minimum wage is.
I'm not advocating for the wage to be seven
25 anywhere to be clear, but I am saying that
in some places, 15 may not actually be the
right number to achieve what it is that, that
we should be looking to achieve.
Okay.
Well thanks David.
All right, appreciate the call.
Thank you so much